the media the press at least the popular
press is is trying to hold us back going
back the other way
I mean they were they're very good at
saying what's happening today but the
idea that we're moving towards something
is not a part of our mainstream media
they're much more concerted on a
military threat somewhere or or friction
between two countries they'd love they
love reporting on that fear they're
actually yeah it's a they self fear is
what really is going on well it turns
out that countries are are not putting
up with that as much anymore so
countries are sort of saying we'll look
we got a bad dictator we got we got
Facebook we got Twitter we got an email
we can we can spread the word and have
the overthrow of a bad government and
that kind of thing is going to start
happening or I mean spread the word get
out of this country and leave that guy
to fall under his own weight I think
we've got it is going to be a really
interesting time we're going we're about
to go through something that is more
interesting than the internet more
interesting than I think anything that's
happened since we were first tribal all
of a sudden we've got this new thing
humanity is going to go through this new
change and it may not change again for
20,000 years inclusive fitness yeah this
open open transparent world that that
all kind of figures out how to operate
and I think that that that figuring out
is going to be a really interesting
opportunity and you're gonna see a
number of different breakthroughs and a
lot of it does come from new
technologies new technologies open the
open people's eyes to new ways of
thinking